[Music]
uncle world's most identical twins
uh celebrate their birthday with their
mutual fiance
who is trying to get them both pregnant
at the exact same time well yo this is
like a porno dream you gotta have two
dicks man you can't do that at the same
time yeah that's one way can you say
that one more time
the most identical yes has they have one
fiance yes one mutual fiancee
they share one that's the mirror filter
is that i've always thought about this
and there's been times on jk where we've
had this topic come up about twins and
having sex with twins
at the same time is that considered
incest at all i think that's considered
amazing is that frowned upon though for
the sister someone's gotta be frowning
at that if i had two twin daughters and
they were [ __ ] the same dude yeah i
think the dad might be frowning but at
the same time why are you thinking like
that though
what do you mean dude do you want to
know what's grosser than that
twin zest porn you ever seen that i like
it it's not gross immediate naughty from
germany that's even worse it's it's
doing lesbians doing lesbian [ __ ] with
each other yeah that's against the bible
oh and there's no other human being
there it's just just the two actual
twins doing [ __ ] with each other or it's
just two white people that look really
similar but don't people like variety in
general let me ask a question okay so we
have two twins sisters right and they're
doing lesbian stuff is that hot that's
hot right hell yeah so let's say you
have wait that's incest though but let's
say thank you jason thank you are you
anti are you are you homophobic it's
both it's incest and gay
how's that homophobic with it's okay to
make out with each other yeah but not
when you're sisters
i agree
that's where his line is i'm making out
you could have like a kiss but not you
can't be fingering each other's [ __ ]
you're like is this gay it's like yeah
it's kind of gay but also you guys are
brothers that's the problem it's not the
game that's not the game but they're
twins though
yeah that's not sisters that's not
sisters that's like that's a clothes
that's like a mirror
yeah you know what i think it is
i think it's a 90s thing like is it
narcissism or is it incest you know
i think me and joe grew up on a
different generation of pornos where
that was like it was very popular there
was a twin genre you guys are separating
us as if you guys are in a different
century right now i remember i i've seen
twin stuff and i feel very weird about
it you've never seen a threesome where
they're wearing a matching outfit i want
to see what the [ __ ] the hype was
about you know i want to see and i
watched it and i was like this is not
for me wait did you jerk off to it
though no oh okay no i found some other
strap-on stuff that i jerked off
what were you saying joe
you were saying it's on the joe and i
interrupted you my bad i forgot yeah um
why is this a bad thing i'm not saying
nobody why are people judging a
threesome okay we're just saying that
this is uh slightly interesting so anna
and lucy the [ __ ] the sink i don't
know dubbed the world's most identical
twins are celebrating their 36th
birthday with their shared fiance ben
byrne okay are they mongolian or
something
yeah that's gonna change our opinion on
all of this yeah i don't think so
um
because culturally when i saw their
photo they look like
mongolian
just making noodles
is that grape pond they work at the
great genghis khan mongolian barbecue at
the mall yeah dude yellow noodles the
reason why these uh these two are quote
unquote the most identical twins is
because they actually not only are they
uh actual identical twins but they also
spent a total of a quarter million
dollars on cosmetic surgery to look even
more alike so any slight variations or
anything that they had they're like
constantly trying that's like their
thing they want to share and live one
life no that makes me want to throw up
yeah that's cheating so twin sex is like
that's pretty cool right but doing that
[ __ ] that's just weird now i'm judging
do you think the guy wants to be
confused like oh who's this one yeah
what i mean it's like a turn on maybe
yeah it's like a king i think i think
that might be a byproduct of it but i
think that there's there's other pros
that might supersede his priority list
like what do you think like just the
idea that he's just got two
of one thing versus two different people
it's like he's got two of one thing and
that's got to be like efficient
how i don't want two of one i don't want
you know no like it's not the same one
what's the point you want morality right
one of ones you don't want two
complaining you want just why two
different complaining yeah yeah do you
want two toyota camrys
see i think it would be effective and
efficient if i use one on sunday i
wouldn't rather have like a toyota camry
and something else like a minivan or a
truck or a miata why do you have two why
do you have two 45 plates on the end of
your bottle why don't you just use one i
only use one
no i only use it
quite heavy for me
from now on he's going to be posting all
his fitness videos to pcu
just to make
he goes into his own james all right
from now on only one side guys only odd
number of plates in here
everybody on their they're all buff on
one side
yeah i go to barbell brigade
so uh it's again not just looking alike
that the twins mirror each other they
also act almost identically uh they eat
together they shower together and they
even go to the toilet together super
annoying uh they are literally trying to
wait they go to the toilet together so
one sits down and the other one sits on
the other one's lap and then they piss
together
or they got custom homes where it's like
double toilets double everything i think
it's more the idea they go at the same
time in order to sink it's almost like
sinking you know what i mean oh i'm
downstairs or upstairs dude maybe i
don't know the details it doesn't say
who's upstairs and downstairs when
they're using the lavatory but
i'm pretty sure it's more the idea of
like sinking their human skin that's so
tiring sleeping at the same time
brushing your teeth at the same time
eating at the same time your your
regular bodily functions just being in
sync with another human being you know
what it is it's they're the real
soulmate and then this other guy they're
just using him totally they just need
sperm but you know what though if you're
a guy that's into kinks from the 90s
like you know and like you're entered
into twin stuff like you hit the jackpot
right here right and also if you guys go
snorkeling in um hawaii together right
and one of them dies because of [ __ ]
puffer fish stun gum or something then
you still have the other one it's a
really yeah specific cause of death
yeah i hate when that happens when an
identical twin dies by [ __ ] puffer
fish if you're swimming with your twin
things are probably connected
and it goes to one like it's like a y oh
yeah or they might share the swim
or twin puffers come in and kill them
both no
twin puffers
but that's why people had a lot of kids
because it's like oh one of them's
probably gonna die that's what's weird
is like the fantasy about twins is is
not to marry them right that's not the
fantasy
speak for yourself
like that wasn't it right when you're
watching the porn you're not like wanna
marry these did you guys grow up with
any twins like in high school or middle
school or anything like that yeah and
they sometimes talk to at the same time
but like most of the time all the twins
that i've known they were always like
obviously a little annoyed that everyone
like mixed them up but they were very
distinct and like i am this person when
you got to know them yeah like i told
you they didn't want to be still dressed
the same i mean it helps when they have
different styles like new york minute or
some [ __ ] like yeah ashley olsen and her
they are like one's the rocker and one i
went to high school with a pair of twins
like that one was like a rocker girl and
one was like kind of preppy but then
eventually they both became kind of like
gothi yeah they went goth oh yeah we
just gotta make sense right if there's a
dynamic of identical twins out there
that like are trying so much to have
their own identity there's got to be
these like really really interesting
unique cases where people are like
trying super desperately to be as one
yeah one in a million how is he gonna
make them both pregnant is he gonna jizz
on his hands and stick it like that like
spiderman
he's just gonna bust the nut twice that
night in two separate there's that's the
gap right he's trying to do it in sync
oh yeah the same second it's
unacceptable any other way you gotta
like like come and then yeah but that's
but you don't even know because the
sperm might be you know i mean slower in
the tube that's true that's true i
wonder why you gotta push harder on one
i wonder why they didn't just get with
the another twin set of dudes that's
weird bro
that is yeah it is good luck that's
weird that is that yeah two thousands
porn
[Laughter]
twin step brother
yeah it does says the pair the pair even
wants their identical nature to extend
to their children uh so they are trying
to both get pregnant at the same time by
the same guy so that their kids are as
similar as possible which might even be
weirder once they try to like
impress upon the following generation
that same concept like you need to be
exactly like your cousin or some [ __ ]
it's weird too because they're not
they're not gonna be twins they're just
gonna be they're gonna be cousin
siblings look exactly they're not gonna
marry each other no but they're also
because the same guy they're also gonna
be siblings so cousin sibling oh weird
damn dude mongolians are wild
[Laughter]
goldens are wild mongolians are
different now huh tell me these guys
don't look mongolian to you that's great
con genetics that's what it is i don't
even know what they are he wants to is
it this great khan genetics we are this
side
not here you did 23 of me didn't you and
that's what i wish i was hoping to see
if i was a little like a little great
khan in me but it just told me i'm 99
chinese go figure you know you literally
look like the prodigal son of genghis
khan dude thank you bro once i grow
these things out it's over bro it's over
would you get that helmet nick looks
like he should be wearing those silk
suits and has his hands tucked in like
this so you're pretty much
so you're pretty much you're more lube
than you are genghis khan
for sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you